13 OF THEM WERE UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN.
THEY ARE ALSO TO BE IN GOOD
IS NOW IN CUSTODY.
YOU CAN EXPECT A BIG PUSH FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP TONIGHT FOR HIS
BORDER WALL.
EVEN THOUGH CONGRESS HAS NOT YET
APPROVED FUNDING FOR IT.
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT WILLIAM
LA JEUNESSE TELLS US WORK ON
>> SAN DIEGO BEFORE A FENCE.
ACCORDING TO THE BORDER PATROL.
>> THEY ARE MAKING THEIR MOVE.
>> ILLEGAL TRAFFIC DOWN 90%.
>> THAT'S MEXICO.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, YOU HAVE A
SECONDARY FENCE.
BUT THOSE WHO WORK HERE SAY THEY
DO.
>> REDUCED THE AMOUNT OF
TRAFFIC, THE FLOW OF MIGRATION
>> EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT BARRIERS
JACK HAMMERS, SAWS AND TORCHES
TO THE LATEST PROTOTYPES.
WHEN YOU WALK UP TO THOSE
PROTOTYPES AND SEE A 25 TO
30-FOOT WALL, IT IS DAUNTING.
>> TACTICAL TEAMS TRIED CLIMBING
THE WALLS.
ONE MATED TO THE TOP AND
COULDN'T GET DOWN.
YES, BUT YOU DISCOURAGES MERCY
CAN AND YOU'RE DEALING WITH A
SMALLER PORTION THAT YOU HAVE TO
>> EACH BORDER SECTOR WILL
EXTEND AND EXISTING FENCE,
REPLACE OLD FRIENDS OR AT A WALL
REPLACE OLD FRIENDS OR AT A WAL
WALL.
>> I DON'T THINK DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING NO TO A WALL, NOTED
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING IS
LET'S BE SMART ABOUT IT.
>> BASED ON TESTING, MANY AGENTS
PREFER A STYLE OF FENCE WITH
ANTI-SCALING CONCRETE ON TOP.
THEY CAN SEE THROUGH IT.